all right so here's the uh the first
story that we have and this one's gonna
get spicy we got this video clip from
Stephen Crowder titled I didn't want to
do this Crowder has issued a response to
Jeremy boring's response in it Stephen
Crowder releases some audio notably uh
well let me let me see if I can play
this do we have the audio properly set
up yep
here we go we'll play the beginning
they don't get deals that they see wage
slaves for a little bit come over and
make a salary and grow their brand
basically wave slaves for a little bit
[Applause]
for a little bit
God bless the talk boy those things are
almost like five thousand dollars now
it's an expensive gag
um that is kind of crazy I didn't
realize they were so expensive yeah all
right so I used to do it this is I mean
this is gonna this is a tough one uh
Steven's not here to defend himself but
Candace is here to to give her
perspective on this so I'll just throw
it to you and give me your thoughts on
on his response and what happened with
the daily wire because I know you got a
lot to say I do have a lot to say about
this because obviously the situation
impacted me and impacted all of the
other hosts on The Daily wire so first
of all I feel like I just want to say
this which is that I have never once
I've moved daily wire two to three years
now you have never once heard me come
out to defend the daily wire on anything
this is not the first time Dilly wire
has been in a firestorm or has been had
some beef that has gone on whether it's
for Ben or Matt or Michael that's going
on the last three years I tend to stay
very much in my Lane as I mentioned
before I'm not an employee of a daily
wire I'm not required to come out and
defend them and I'm usually just not
interested in these beefs that seem to
be so fickle they last for a day and
then they go away and it's probably the
reason why for whatever doesn't really
matter anybody thinks got me I have a
good relationship with pretty much
everybody like there's no one that I
can't be invited and be in the same room
with everybody sort of hates each other
but I'm kind of I can Alex Jones has a
good opinion of me everyone from Alex
Jones to Ben Shapiro and Paul Joseph
Watson Mike cernovich is somebody that I
call and ask for advice from time to
time Jack wasobic like I I'm a kind of
person that judges People based on how
they treat people right I'm not
interested in dabbling in this nonsense
um nonsense from time to time it appears
and then goes away and Ebbs and flows
this situation though was different
because basically Stephen Crowder
decided to launch a war and didn't
really care who got hit you know with
the shrapnel right he comes out he makes
this glorious video which it's shocking
to me that people cannot see the amount
of acting that is going into this we all
understand he's a childhood actor he was
on I loved that show Arthur he was the
brain like he he is an actor at the end
of the day he's an actor it's also why
he's so entertaining when it comes to
politics he's a talented person but that
people cannot discern the amount of
action that has gone on this is stunning
to me I don't know where people's
discernment what's going on with
discernment where you can't just
spiritually discern that this feels a
little weird right you're recording
conversations with someone that you have
told us you are friends with forever oh
and by the way at the end of you saying
that you're just trying to do the right
thing you're also saying I'm going to
launch my own thing right so just when I
first saw the first video that he
dropped obviously I'm not privy to
negotiations that happened on The Daily
wire I had no idea they were negotiating
with Stephen Crowder again not my
business I came into work one day
suddenly Brett Cooper was there not my
business I don't know who they're hiring
I don't own the company right but what I
started getting was after I had dropped
my podcast in the comments section
everyone was basically tearing me apart
being like blink twice if you need help
for a single like I'm a hostage
situation or saying what if you don't
say anything about Stephen Crowder
you're a fraud you're a fraud just like
suddenly you're a fraud you're a fraud
so I go and I watch this video and just
like everybody else watching it live his
first video your instincts are like whoa
he's throwing some bombs he's calling it
big con he's saying essentially that we
are enslaved by these contract terms he
actually uses the term enslavement if
you don't want to be a slave you know
you may be a common to figure it out for
all of us like you're a hero you're a
martyr and because I was getting so many
comments the first thing I did was that
I messaged my EP and I said we have to
cover this tomorrow on the show because
now everyone thinks I'm a fraud and they
think that I've signed with fraudulents
or slave-like terms and that's so
totally unfair to me so my interest in
this is that it hit me and it hit
everybody else's daily wire and it was
unfair do you I don't know you don't
have to answer this I guess but do you
have a similar contract there are
certain terms I recognize that's why I
immediately knew was daily wire so for
example the um the fee reduction if you
miss a day of work right like if you
miss a day of work we are paying for x
amount of episodes and this is a steep
amount if you miss one day of work when
you first see that when I first received
a contract from a daily wire I went
that's a shocking number to see then you
have to calculate and by the way mine
was not this one be very clear I don't
have a 50 million dollar contract if
there's anything I should be upset about
is that they were going to pay that much
Stephen Crowder right I need to go
renegotiate my contract but so you see
it and it's shocking and then you read
under which is what he did not include
when he says so if I could hit by a car
like I'm just gonna a hundred thousand
dollars a day he didn't tell you how
much he made you don't know what hundred
thousand dollars means unless you can
see what were they offering him and you
can calculate yourselves okay so what
they're basically saying is that we're
paying you sixty three thousand dollars
that you know what I'm saying he he
purposely like excluded right beneath it
that says that actually it's Pro rata
it's an event of an emergency that's a
very insignificant thing that would
allow people not to be enraged at seeing
this yeah just to clarify Jeremy when
Jeremy uh released his video he showed
the the additional portion that said in
the of temporary disability they prorate
you there's no penalty and then we
talked about this last night I said the
hundred thousand dollars seems punitive
I think you mentioned yeah but what
about daily wires costs I said oh yeah
Fair Point DC joined it and that is
exactly right they have all of these
contracts that exist it's very easy to
understand we're paying you here's this
is 100 we're paying you sixty three
thousand dollars for the content they
are also have a bunch of contracts
everybody's working on the show so for
example my EP she's contracted I don't
know what a contract says and maybe it
says that no matter what she is
guaranteed this amount of money so if I
magically call out they still have to
pay her they still have to pay the
camera guy maybe the advertising is
punitive if you didn't give us the
content the advertisers maybe then say
okay you JLo I actually pay us five
thousand dollars of cash doesn't read
ads on that day you don't know when you
have an organization this big what
everybody's contracts are so I assume
it's sixty thousand dollars and then
they're baking in an extra 38 000 to
cover their assets to pay everybody else
that maybe showed up for work that day
but Jeremy did say punitive it is
because he said well you're right about
the costs all around it but he said he
basically said one circumstance is
you're choosing not to work and one is
you're unable to work right if you're
unable we get it we'll just we'll just
prorate based on the Lost day but he
also says it'd be interesting that you
could you could make up that day by
banking it at any time right so I do
that by the way I do that and that's why
it's so annoying so I see these things
it's to people who don't know how this
works first and foremost it's a term
sheet he was never given a contract it
was a term street it's essentially a
starting conversation here's what we
have in mind everything's baked in some
things literally don't make sense like
in my term sheet it said you know we uh
whatever about they wanted access to my
Snapchat I don't have a Snapchat they
wanted access to my room unofferable
they don't want access it's literally
just like here's something so we can get
the conversation started started and
really I think you need to pay attention
to is like this is the money and then of
course our lawyer's gonna go back and
say this makes entirely no sense this
makes entirely no sense so then you get
to you know personalize it so to speak
right when you say okay well this thing
makes me me nervous because okay what if
it's not me that's sick but my son I
have two kids right what if my son
breaks his leg and I have to be I'm not
going to not leave his side so I have I
have to then say I need to personalize
this term sheet and that is what the
contract is done for if you come to some
agreement that this is what we're going
to work on right this is what we're
going to negotiate in good faith right
so he first and foremost lied by saying
it was a contract he lied by Omission by
not saying how much money so people
couldn't calculate okay really how
punitive is that 100 000 not that much
and you consider that there's a bunch of
costs that go in to producing a show and
and people that they may have paid
editors in this case he produces his own
show but you know editors writers no
matter what daily wire has to receive
that package and do something to it so
and by the way like I said we know it's
at least standard so it's not because
they're trying to hit Steven Crowder
they've given this to all of us and your
job then if you're a big boy right if
you can put on your big boy pants is to
go to your lawyer and to say I'm not
doing that I'm not doing that this makes
no sense negotiate now if you are a
young talent that was discovered on
YouTube as I was way back in the day who
comes from no money as I was way back in
the day this could be like unfair
because I can't afford a lawyer to go
through line by line of this and Redline
this that is not the circumstance
receiving Crowder he's already told us
he's got so much money he's more
successful and he doesn't need the money
blah blah blah so why don't you just
hire a lawyer but that that's what he
said in the rebuttal yeah it's not about
me it's about the daily wire signing new
upcoming young people to these terms and
they don't and in that and in that
capacity he hits Brett Cooper right now
he's basically so who who is a young
upcoming talent that got signed there's
only what five hosts of shows on The
Daily wire I mean so you're talking
about Matt Walsh no he's not young
upcoming Talent that's just been science
you're talking about Michael Knowles no
he's not young you're not talking about
cancer I don't think we would say Andrew
Cleveland is Young upcoming Talent so
you're talking about Brett Cooper that's
insulting to Brett Cooper you have no
idea he's just saying right and
it's not like he's reached out to us and
said hey like I'm doing this for all of
us like he's not he reached out
independently to daily wire host and
been like are you dealing with this
agreed these egregious terms no he is
doing this purely let's not even try to
make this anything but a selfish act
that was to benefit Stephen Crowder who
wants to launch his own network because
and by the way I gotta say this is the
most important part of this and nobody
is talking about this he receives the
term sheet okay and he thinks it's so
egregious that he's got to make this
video four months later right I don't
know what happened in those four months
after they started negotiating I guess
Stephen Crowder woke up new year new me
I hate that I hate the daily wire so I'm
gonna go after them he thinks it's so
egregious the first thing he does is
counter offer and say let's start
talking about 140 million okay so if it
was so outrageous why did he go back to
them and say no actually we can have
this conversation but let's start
talking about 140 million right it was
only one of the daily wire then turned
that down that the term sheet became so
egregious that he had to do something
about it I'll I'll just add real quick
to everybody Stephen Crowder is coming
on the show on Monday I know he's not
here to defend himself did you speak to
him because he might have recorded your
conversation
I mean yeah my view is I was kind a
surprise to hear that Stephen recorded
the phone call with Jeremy because um I
don't I don't know why you would
oh um by the way it should be mentioned
that conversation so they stopped
negotiating completely which Jeremy made
clear in his video this was over he
doesn't even know what this coming from
because this this conversation stopped
when Stephen Crowder then came back with
a counter term sheet offer of what a
glorious 140 million dollars over x
amount of years and they said we just
can't do this right then he sat and he
stewed and he said nothing until one
week ago he reaches out to Jeremy and he
asks him to talk on the phone and that
was one week ago that is the
conversation that you are guys are all
hearing that he is playing right now so
he plotted this this is a plot line he
planned to them record him to go back
and to make this video If this if he had
recorded this way back during
negotiations maybe you could say there
was no plot why did he reach out to
Jeremy exactly one week ago when they
hadn't discussed anything pertaining to
the contract and they said no one walked
away last year around October November
and then suddenly in January he reaches
out when we can go and says hey can we
get on the phone and he decides maybe I
should record this no it's because he he
realized he had nowhere left to go and
his next plot in this storyline in this
terrible childhood acting he's doing
right now was okay I have to do my own
thing now and so I need to drum up some
drama to get everybody that I know to
believe that I am a martyr for our
beliefs and they should dump their
subscriptions to everybody else it's
part of VidCon and join the mug Club how
can people not see I mean the writing is
just so on the wall
the fact that he recorded Jeremy says
that he did plan you know if you look
I'm not I'm not here to impugn his honor
I think you're absolutely entitled to
your view having you know working with
the daily wire and everything you've
seen but uh it like it does suggest that
he knew he was calling Jeremy for this
reason I think I think Crowder is um I
don't I don't know if I I think it might
be too far for me to believe that
Crowder is trying to do this to pull
subscribers from daily wire or make more
money for himself because the Dude
already makes a lot of money but not he
he does not he he thinks that he is
worthy of 140 million dollars a year do
you believe that Stephen Crowder right
now is making 140 million dollars I bet
he could you bet he could absolutely you
bet he could but how's he got to do that
how's he going to start that he just had
a couple of kids how's he going to start
that you launch a war in a conservative
movement and you move people away from a
business that you want to model you know
I don't know who's modeling who I don't
know who started this first but you
basically say I'm not them come with me
and that's exactly what he's doing call
a spade a spade call a spade a spade
okay this was a plot line and that
annoys me because he dragged me into the
this plot line okay he dragged us onto
this pot line he's basically saying oh
well he at one point in his video this
is what really set me off he's like and
so you might be noticing that a lot of
these people
um their viewpoints are sanitized and
this is why this contract this is why
essentially saying that Candace is
controlled Matt Walsh is controlled
Michael Knowles is controlled Brett
Cooper is controlled and now we know why
guys because I have this contract which
I've conveniently exerted portions that
could allow you to discern for yourself
but it's actually not that unreasonable
as a starter conversation which is what
a term sheet is right and instead I'm
just going to smear all these people
that are associated wire and that's why
I'm pissed off that's why I'm pissed off
because I then was Fielding comments
calling me a fraud because they thought
that I agreed to these terms and that my
voice was being controlled you know what
I told Stephen I said
um I think ideologically I understand
he's right with the contracts and I and
I agree with the contracts we don't we
don't do contracts the way the daily
wire does there was no contractor just
want to say that one more well right so
uh contract different term um terms I
don't I don't do terms the way the daily
wire does I also am you know the way
it's it's like The Joe Rogan story I
have to tell that he booted me from a
show twice and I didn't get mad at him I
was like well I'm kind of I'm kind of
pissed off that he he booted me twice
like happened twice and I flew out to LA
but he doesn't know many favors I'm not
gonna rag on Joe Rogan because he didn't
do me a favor if I was on a show be
really great for me it didn't work out
I'm going to carry on with my life and
my business I've negotiated with the
daily wire we couldn't we couldn't
figure out something that worked we're
very different in that sense and I said
well you know it was nice hanging out
and let's let's work on stuff in the
future and we'll make awesome stuff I
told Stephen I said I think that the
daily wire is a massive net positive
especially with like what is a woman I
mean that was a massive cultural force
that got even made mainstream like
moderate Lefty types to be like oh yeah
I've seen that and start this
conversation uh then you did the BLM
documentary of course that had uh I I
don't think it was nearly as big as what
as a woman but certainly had a cultural
response these things are tremendous and
so my attitude is like look
I don't I don't I don't like the the
contracts of like they're very they're
very business-like the very
entertainment industry
I understand that that daily wire does
it if someone came to me and said we're
going to get investors we're going to
get some prominent conservative voices
and we're going to launch a company that
Rivals Disney I'd be like man I don't
like Disney and they'll go yeah yeah but
it will be America loving independently
minded meritocratic I'll say oh I'll
take that over Disney any day and then
I'll go and do my thing that I think
should be the way I want it to be and
I'm not gonna be mad at the daily wire
for the daily wire doing a thing like
yeah Bill what you're describing first
and foremost are the free markets right
if you don't like it somewhere leave I
thought we were conservatives I thought
that's what you're trying to preserve
right a free market mentality if this if
daily wire is so awful right and so
predatory and treating their talent so
horrifically they'd have no Talent right
then literally Stephen Crowder wouldn't
have to launch a war you just have to
launch an alternative business with
better contract and people would leave
willingly they would say there's more
money there there's better treatment I'm
leaving that's what the free markets
work right because he did not feel maybe
he's feeling a little insecure he
thought that he was a free agent he
feels like he's Tom Brady everyone's
gonna make me all these offers and he
thought came in extremely low Tom Brady
I'm Tom Brady why am I getting offered
50 million dollars that should be
offered 140 million dollars and the team
says no thank you Tom Brady and then he
goes oh I'm effing Tom Brady well the
truth is it's like I think Stephen
Crowder was feeling insecure I think he
was reeling after those negotiations I
think there are very few conservative
networks that can offer him that money
he's actually you know he's burned a few
Bridges right Fox News he's burned a
bridge he's burned a bridge with the
blaze how many other companies in the
conservative movement does he think can
reasonably afford to pay him what he
thinks he's worth right the daily wire
so when he was done I think that he was
feeling tremendously insecure right when
those negotiations failed in October or
November he stewed on it in November in
December came up in January and decided
okay I'm gonna have to launch my own
outfit I'm gonna go after the daily wire
and his plot line included calling
Jeremy Boren catching him on camera on
on we only have seen a piece of his
conversation Jeremy has already tweeted
that he called him like hey let's catch
up and then and now he's he was like
let's talk about the kids and Christmas
they were friends very close friends
okay Steve even Crowder has said they
were friends not colleagues not
Associates not you know like I would say
me and Matt Walsh and what were
Associates but friends he called his
friend to talk about Christmas and his
kids and instead he recorded him and
then dropped that recording a week later
pretending that he was doing this to to
be a martyr I just don't see how people
don't realize this guy is a bad a
fundamentally bad person like I I don't
understand how this is even a debate the
phone call thing's rough I mean Who
records their friends with friends like
these who needs enemies who needs the
left and we've got friends like these in
the conservative movement and but the
other thing too is I say it's about
project Veritas I think Veritas should
release the raw when they when they do
this stuff like there's a lot of stuff
that Veritas has done it's been very
very important but I'm often like you
know it could quash a lot of these
arguments about deceptive editing if you
just say like we editorialized here's
the raw footage you can see for yourself
minus private information if there's
like addresses or phone numbers and this
in this context I'm really not a fan of
Snippets being released because it's
like okay well what what led up to that
moment yeah well I said wage slaves we
don't we don't know the context of it
sounds to me like he was potentially
asking a question about well do you do
this you know with all your child he's
like well this is different you're a big
person coming in and where we don't have
to put as much money behind you so we're
concerned that you're gonna have an ad
drop if you're a new person you're
saying you come to the Daily wire and by
this is completely a guess I have no
idea you're coming daily wire and you're
like hey I want to try this thing you
know can you make can you make my name
bigger essentially you're saying like
here are the wages we're going to pay
you you're going to work your ass off
you know what I mean and you have the
the benefit of having the entire daily
wire Network behind you I think he was
probably trying to describe again I have
no idea the different mentality between
getting Talent like Stephen Crowder and
trying to get him in a contract where
she's getting Talent that's new and it's
looking to come a daily wire because
they basically absorb all the benefit
again I don't know but it is exactly
that's probably what he was saying and
now he excerpted wage slaves as if he
like was uh these pump these slaves that
are working for me I mean it's it's a
colloquialism you know what I mean he's
using that term not seriously but it
allows him to play that excerpt to make
it sound like this is how the daily wire
treats their employees I mean it's just
horrible stuff that he's doing with
daily wire Jeremy was saying that if a
new person with no audience comes to
daily wire they're basically going to
put him on a contract with a wage and
then they're going to own all the
content that they say they're going to
own and then when the person's done off
the contract they can go continue to be
famous and successful although daily
wire will still own the stuff that they
paid for to get produced while that
person was there and he used the term
wage slave now now I'm with you I don't
think the term the words themselves are
that big of a deal no but he wanted to
come across like a big idea like it's a
very big deal because he's relying on
business ignorance he keeps doing this
he keeps relying on business ignorance
and he's appealing and this is literally
a socialist tactic he's appealing to
like you know the Amazon employees who
want to like Stick it to the Man and
then they boycott May pick it because
they're not getting paid you know fifty
thousand dollars an hour and being
treated to ice cream once a week he's
appealing people that he's like okay
think of yourself as an employee not as
a business person right this is a
business person mindset this is what I
get from this conversation obviously I'm
privy to these these talks with Jeremy
and Caleb this is this is who I
negotiate my contracts with and there
have literally been times because I'm a
big girl and I go and I sit with them
where I say there's no way I'm signing
this line you know they move an inch
this way I'm moving into that way
they're moving into this way you know
and then then here we are we we meet
here in the Middle where we all feel
like this is a good contract and
nobody's a slave right because in order
to sign a contract if you fully
comprehend it you're not a slave you're
just not a slave something I think about
Jeremy personally and not too relevant
but I think he enjoys negotiating I
think so she's amazing why are you got
to know that going into it I want to
enjoys negotiating I want to read a
Super Chat real quick because this is an
important Point uh idg says daily wires
agenda make profit Crowder's agenda
saving American experiment exhibit jbp
deletes tweets supporting Crowder
exhibit B your poll
I'll tell you what I think I don't
completely disagree with that
um I think the daily wire is a machine I
think the daily wire is a machine that
is not the ideological like system that
I would personally build we do things
very differently here the people who are
here are on salary with no terms like if
you if if pop culture crisis got bad
this is a small company that's how it is
when you work for me I have a company
too a small company where we have seven
employees and it's familial you see
Savannah's downstairs we get to hang out
and do fun things we're a small company
if we grew and we suddenly had 400
employees things have to get a lot more
serious and professional that's true but
I'm I'm and I've talked to Jeremy a lot
about this and so it may just be a great
we're small and then you know he's like
when you get bigger man you're going to
run into these things and I'm like maybe
but here's my thing
I I like the daily wire I think the
daily wire is uh I think Jeremy and uh
you know everybody else involved and
Union James one made the video are
seeking to to make money and and use
that money and and build more and make
more money if the daily wire succeeds
and makes money and then makes more
movies and makes more documentaries that
means we're gonna get more what is a
woman it means we're gonna get more you
know Gina caranos it means Hollywood
will be weakened it means as Hollywood
falls from the hill a machine that
actually at least to some degree shares
our values will be there it may be in
your opinion a cold faceless machine but
at least the cold face faceless machine
is saying meritocracy meritoc I'll be
like okay well well LOL to anyone who
thinks that Stephen Crowder is not doing
this to make money like I mean I just
have to outwardly laugh he's he's the
person in in a disguise he's a wolf in
sheep's clothing right he's he's like
I'm not I'm here because I care about
all of you that's why I'm recording my
friend and doing this crappy thing where
I literally could have just said no I
don't like those terms and then said to
everybody I'm starting my own outfit
fair you walk away all the time you have
to go you I have walked away you know I
had an offer from the blaze it didn't
work for me you know what I mean I don't
need to piece apart the the contract I
love those guys I think Tyler is amazing
this is what I'm saying people need to
stop thinking that he is some knight in
shining armor he's not he's not a knight
in shining armor and if you can't see
that watch this video because I think
his acting is never more apparent even
the titles I didn't want to do this oh
really then why the hell did you record
him
what were you doing that for do you
think you're gonna go to airport you
think you're gonna go to court because
that's the only reason you record
someone you'd be like I don't trust my
ex wife pardon my language okay
I don't trust my ex-wife so I'm gonna
record this phone call for safety right
you record it because you're nervous if
there's going to be a court hero or the
police are going to find out you've got
to back up what you said okay why are
you recording your friend if not because
you think it's going to go to court oh
because you think it's going to go to
public and you're doing it intentionally
because you know you're about to start a
war people please use your common sense
I am not even it's not even because I
work daily wire it is because he
personally is he's lying and he insulted
me and during his his lion campaign he's
still lying he even said something in
this video where he's like now they're
sending out there no no you took if
you're gonna aim and you're gonna hit
somebody with shrapnel it's gonna be me
you better incorrectly because I don't
like like this okay I have been
quiet I know Steven Crowder treats
people like like absolute trash it's a
known thing in the concerned movement
ask anybody that works the place any
questions ever had to show on the place
how Stephen Crowder treats people by the
way you want to talk about contract
negotiations why doesn't somebody reach
out to not get Jared right who used to
be with Stephen Crowder and figure out
why he can't speak why isn't Stephen
Crowder release not gay Jared from his
NDA I don't like like this that's
all I'm saying I don't like it I want
both daily wire and Crowder to succeed
that's what we all wanted who cares
movie yeah something like Lethal Weapon
man me and Steve it's gonna be crazy I
mean Luke Luke's sitting here I don't
know he's straight man
I'm like this is like well you know WWE
let me explain I personally just uh you
know I I personally don't care to be
honest I want to try and like I I want
to talk about the globalist we will
I think that what happened Stephen well
first of all why was he recording I
think that's a you know fair question
but we don't doesn't need to be answered
in Texas it's legal to record it's a
one-party consent state so it's like
saying why is he open carrying a gun
because he's planning to shoot someone
like you don't know why he's got a gun
you don't know why he's recording and it
really doesn't matter but but recording
is the action like if he had a tape
recorder when he made the phone call and
didn't record I'd say that argument is
is comparable right for all I know
everyone in Texas is recording every
conversation at every moment and they
have a right to do that and maybe even a
responsibility at this stage of reality
I don't know you know things you say can
be taken out of context if you don't
have the protection of your for yourself
secondly I think what Steven said in
this video that we're probably not going
to watch other thirds pretty long or
what 20 minutes 18 minutes is that he's
not concerned about the money but I
agree with you Candace he did say I
can't do 50 million I need 140 uh
something about City about 30 million a
year is what he was looking for Jeremy
said that I think 30 million and then
Crowder said he counter offered yeah
he's like so why'd you counter off her
before you decide the terms weren't
available so after that after they
realized the money that's not an option
we can't do 140. uh Stephen said then
you got to take these uh demonetization
negative penalties out from like if I
violate YouTube's terms because now
you're an arm of big Tech because you're
making me follow YouTube's terms of
service you're basically a lap dog for
YouTube but Crowder follows their terms
of service too we all do that's the
whole point the first
behind the paywall let's let's not get
let's be responsible let's not get
banned yeah let's talk about the 99
things we can and then the other stuff
we can put on timcast.com so that we can
slide the conversation oh you're
Shilling for big Tech you're what you're
part of VidCon now you're all a part of
VidCon because you're being smart and
you don't want to get banned until we
have a comparable platform to go to
listen to perfect world we would all
wish that we could do I invest all of my
time in trying to support companies and
sometimes they fail and it sucks you
know what I mean like I really believed
in glorified banking it crashed you know
I really believe in the free the freedom
phone that didn't work out we all want
an alternative and we meaningfully want
an alternative we just don't have them
we're not there yet as a conservative
movement so while we're not there yet is
our we're just all gonna what just shoot
ourselves in the foot and be nowhere to
prove that we were a real one right oh
it shows that you're a gangster because
you got shot in your chest nine times if
you don't get shot in your chest nine
times you're not a real gangster like a
real effective stupid fighter against
that is to use the momentum of Silicon
Valley against itself or it for your
favor like you Jitsu it I don't think
pushing back is The Right Use of energy
it requires too much so I you want to
use these platforms to one get the word
out about new platforms and two as
hosting thanks for watching this clip
from the timcast IRL podcast hang out
with us live Monday through Friday at 8
pm and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
shows exclusive thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time